hello this is steve kaufman again my
wife carmen and i are in la quinta near
palm springs we're about to go off and
play some golf
now i did um a video with a person
called martin chuck who runs the tour
striker golf academy where my wife and i
took
golf lessons for three straight days and
then i did an interview with martin
which you'll see shortly where we talked
about
similarities or differences between
learning languages and learning golf
and there are some similarities uh and
martin points this out you'll hear him
say that it's important to have goals
it's important that uh people don't
think there's some pixie dust as he says
some instant cures or
uh shortcuts it's a lot of hard work and
gradually building up on one's skills
he talks about the kinds of goals that
he would have if he were to learn a
language which would relate to say
traveling to spain and playing golf
there because what he likes to do is to
play golf so a lot of these things kind
of relate to language learning the way
the way i perceive it which is that you
have to enjoy what you're doing you have
to build up gradually it takes a lot of
time
but there are also some major
differences
golf is a skill which you
have to train
and from my own experience you can get
better for a while then you get worse
for a while because it involves the
control of so many muscles and so many
movements
on the other hand with language learning
i find that the more time i put in the
more i progress the more i listen the
more i read the more i speak pardon for
the outdoor noise here
uh the more i accumulate experience with
the language the better i get so to that
extent language learning in a way is
easier because you can you know that if
you have the right attitude and you put
in the effort
you will get better with golf
i'm hoping that with this golf clinic
that uh carmen and i attended that we
will start to get better but i've spent
15 years training largely the wrong way
and my game really hasn't improved on
the other hand in my language learning
if i spend three months six months one
year learning
russian czech romanian portuguese korean
i know that i will get better so
that's just by by way of introduction
we're going to go off and play golf now
i want you to watch the video with
martin chuck and i look forward to your
comments oh and one thing i should add
too
golf becomes an addiction to many people
i don't know how many millions of people
spend lots of money and put in many
hours into improving their golf game and
very few of them do improve on the other
hand language learning you're guaranteed
to improve
uh you get something that's of benefit
that's a benefit in your social life
travel
uh you know uh professional life so i
hope that more people will beg and will
become addicted to learning languages at
any rate enough of me now i hope you
enjoyed the interview with martin chuck
and thanks for listening
hello martin hey what's going on steve
well i just wanted to do a little
interview because carmen my wife and i
have been down here
hi martin improving our golf game well
it's been a pleasure to have you both
here and for those who watch me i don't
normally have a stash but this is for
movember which is men's health month so
get your stuff checked out
and i have my excuse of a mustache on as
well i started a few days late but at
link we also have a movember movement on
martin chuck
runs or is the head pro with revolution
golf i'm one of i'm one of the
contributing coaches on revolution golf
and i'm the inventor of the tour striker
training products that i coached at the
tour striker golf academy
and we discovered or carmen discovered
martin through his videos on youtube
well thank you which we felt amongst all
the different videos we'd seen were the
best that made the most sense and
therefore as a result we came down to
your academy oh thanks but what i want
to talk about because my viewers are
interested they may also be interested
in golf but they're primarily interested
in learning languages
and i was thinking as we were going
through this that you're a coach yes
you're a motivator you're a teacher
and i'm sure there are things in common
between motivating and coaching people
when it comes to learning languages and
when it comes to learning to play golf
better so from your perspective what do
you try to achieve as a coach i try to
you know take people and show them
what's possible you know i mean i think
of in languages and i think man i'd sure
love to learn another language and for
me you know if i was to kind of
say if i was a language coach how would
i inspire people to learn a language i
know what i do
i'd say my goal is to go visit such and
such country france or spain and i can't
wait to go play a golf journey there for
seven days and it might be a year 18
months away and then i think okay i want
to play golf in spain well i want to
learn how to speak the language too so i
would i would set a goal for myself that
i think oh i love playing golf and i
love playing golf in spain and i know i
could get around fine probably in spain
with my english but i would want to
learn the language so i would pick
something that i love which is golf and
then i would do something that i would
aspire to be better at which is a second
language that's how kind of i would do
it okay you know now as it relates to
you you asked me the question i kind of
wanted a tangent right the
you know how i inspire people to play
better golf as i
you know everybody wants the quick fix
they want the pixie dust they want they
just want it now that's the attitude we
have and as a coach i try to inspire
people to understand that it's subtle
skills
that we stack upon one another and we
can build those subtle skills we become
much better much more educated and then
as we're conscious we tend to put we can
automate things you have to learn the
basics in golf you have to learn a few
different things about club face path
how the ball reacts and that's really
stuff you can't there's no shortcuts to
that i'm sure when you're teaching
languages there's no shortcuts to
certain things too and it's not simply a
matter of explaining those things it's a
matter of grooving them right through
the various drills that you showed us
right uh and i think in language
learning too i i have the same approach
i feel that anyone can learn and i think
you encouraged us here we can all become
better right some will be better than
others there are some differences but we
can all improve uh but we have to put
the effort in it's not as you say it's
not pixie dust language learning as well
you know it takes time i always say in
language learning there's three issues
there's attitude yeah whether you like
the language whether you're you know
willing to put the effort in whether
you're fighting the language so attitude
sure the second thing is time yeah and
the third thing is developing that
ability to notice what is happening in
the language you're learning right but
if i refer to if i apply that to golf
works obviously if you don't like the
game of golf if you're not willing to
put in the effort right if you don't put
in the time and if you don't notice the
things that you mentioned for example
how the face of the club hits the ball
right you're gonna have a tough time
improving so there are similarities
that's a great parallel yeah yeah and so
you know and and are you consider
yourself a teacher or a coach
i like to i like to think i'm a conduit
to
you know to somebody learning something
right i mean you know it's hard to teach
golf you know you have to provide
different experiences that somebody goes
oh and they have these subtle little aha
moments and eventually you have a series
of aha moments and then you feel like
you have a certain command and certainty
over what you're doing you know so i
can't just say here do this because
that's not how it works i have to show
you
why you'll feel better about playing
golf when you make these subtle changes
and then you'll feel wow that felt great
and man i have i'm capable of breaking
80 and there's a reason why and a lot of
the stuff out there that people coach
maybe isn't uh
work that well and there's a lot of just
do this because i don't like to say just
do this because i like to explain things
thoroughly so people understand and i
explain it 15 different ways because if
i explain it once that may not do it you
might explain it a bunch of times and
then maybe they hook on to one of those
things exactly yep
and as you say once you have a feeling
of success that inspires you to do more
right and i feel the same is true in
languages you can feel that you're not
getting anywhere then you'll have a
eureka moment right you're in spain you
were at a bar and all of a sudden you
could communicate well with people
exactly that's what keeps people going
so i just wanted to do this interview
because
carmen and i enjoyed it we're down here
in sunny phoenix we had a lovely time
with uh
four other we were six and all six it
was a very intense three days oh yeah we
feel really benefited it was a wonderful
golf school and he worked very hard
and mostly we enjoyed it and i think
that's true of whether it's golf or
language yeah you have to enjoy it so
maybe we can agree on that and we agree
thank you very much thanks mike okay bye